if you want to become an exceptional
hunter then this is the ideal training
ground but from here on out whether we
win or lose it's going to be held during
these fights
I can't keep looking out for you if you
can't beat them then you'd better go
back or else you just be a hindrance
hello and welcome to Hunter hunter 101
series that breaks down everyone and
everything in the Hunter hunter world
and today we are going to be delving
into the stoic student of Jing freaks
and role model of GaN freaks kite kite
is a tall gaunt looking hunter who was
introduced all the way back in Chapter
one of the series he generally appears
very serious and cold-hearted however
underneath that kite has a genuinely
warm nature and is particularly fond of
animals and with that in mind kites
primary action in Chapter one of the
story was to save gone from a fox bear
mother who was attacking him in order to
defend her cub kite regrettably killed
the Fox bear in order to save gone but
then proceeded to chastise the boy for
being ignorant enough to have gotten
himself into this situation which had
effectively robbed an innocent Fox bear
of its life gone took these words to
heart and vowed to raise the cub as
penance prompting kite to ask who the
boy's father was only to discover that
gone was the son of his master Jing
freaks
now unfortunately very little is known
about kites past although the 2011 anime
did expand on it somewhat but in the end
the primary factor of importance was
meeting Jing who saw potential in kite
and took him on as his student teaching
him how to hunt as well as the
principles of nen furthermore kite was
also privy to many of Jing qu's exploits
and was even taken into the game of
greed Island kite would then go on to
take the hunter exam and managed to pass
it with ease however his final test
would come from Jing himself who gave
kite the seemingly simple task of
finding him and yes while that does
sound like a rather glorified game of
hide-and-seek Pak claims that this task
was the most difficult hunt in the world
and in order to achieve it kite had come
to whale island in order to seek out any
information from Jing qu's family now
this stage gone really knew nothing
about his father and it was kind who
inspired him to become a hunter and one
day find Jing himself embarking on the
exact same quest the kite was already on
this was sparked because cat possesses
the utmost respect and admiration for
Jaime and the more kite told gone the
more gone developed his own personal
sense of admiration for his mysterious
father as a parting gift and or
challenge kite even provided gone with
jinx hunters license before departing
the island to complete his task and
eventually he did find Jing although a
notably this was only shown
in the 2011 anime but after this initial
appearance in the very first chapter the
character of kite would be set to Simha
not appearing again until chapter 185
when gone and kilowatt was sent to him
via the power of an accompany card
following their victory on greed Island
at this stage kite had been hired by the
cocoon Kingdom to conduct ecological
research with his own personal team of
aspiring hunters leading to the alarming
discovery of the chimera ants kite
accompanied by gone and kilowatt then
embarked into the neo green life
autonomous state in order to suppress
and exterminate the chimera ant queen
however these creatures who originated
on the dark continent was subject to
rapid evolution so while kite was
initially using chimera ants to test gun
and kill his capabilities things would
shortly take a very serious turn and it
would be here the kites true power would
be displayed for the first time in
regards to nan kite is a conjurer and
his primary use of nan appears in the
form of various weapons with a
smack-talking clown affixed to them
known as crazy swords to activate this
ability kite conjures his clown friend
which commences a slot machine
containing the numbers 1 through 9 with
each of these numbers corresponding to a
different weapon that the crazy
sponsibility has the potential to turn
into the unfortunate kicker is that due
to this random nature kite is unable to
choose what weapon to use in any given
scenario however this was a conditions
specifically attached to the ability in
order to increase the potency of the
weapons conjured in the series thus far
we have only seen three of these numbers
activated one of which results in a
scythe another a carbine and the third
is a very mysterious mace the function
of which was never shown in regards to
this so kites master Jing has mentioned
that there is a number that will only
pop up when kite desperately does not
want to die implying that this mace may
have saved him from being removed from
this world speaking of things escalated
very very quickly during the Chimera ant
arc resulting in F Peter being born a
creature of absurd power who managed to
eclipse even kite in every aspect of
combat this was the situation in which
kite drew slot number 3 the mysterious
mace but whatever power had held it did
not save him as an ephah Peter proceeded
to kill and dismember him now for most
characters in fiction and death by
beheading would be where this video
tragically ends but we do have a couple
of things left to go through here
following his death kites corpse would
go on to play a major role in the story
as it had been adopted by an ephah Peto
and given a form of life through the
doctor Blythe nobility Nefer Peter did
this because they enjoyed their fight so
much
that never Peter desperately wished for
it to happen again so why not let's
raise the dead sort of and after being
discovered by gone kites corpse and the
subsequent revelation fo Peter would be
unable to complete
revive him scent gone into a fit of nin
fueled rage and despair culminating in
the brutal demise of Neffe Beto and yet
we still don't conclude the story there
because kite would actually end up being
reborn into this world through the
Chimera ant queen herself in fact kite
actually popped out at the same time as
Mara when the ant king making them
biological twins this teeny tiny baby
kite was then taken by cult who would
end up betraying the ant Legion and so
kite was raised as a human under the
protection of the hunter Association
until we also may need to change our
pronouns a bit because kite was reborn
into this world as a biological female
furthermore due to the whole being a
chimera and thing kite grew rapidly by
the time the aquas OVA kite had the
appearance of a young teenager to add to
this unlike many humans who were
directly converted into ants kite
appears to retain the memory of her
former self and was delighted when Gahan
came to visit her currently it is
assumed that kite still resides within
the protection of the hunter Association
along with her previous group of
aspiring hunters small fun facts about
kite
having been trained by [ __ ] freaks kite
is one of the more phenomenal uses of
nen in the world with one example being
his profound use of n which can cover a
radius of up to 45 meters and is
completely undetectable to the large
majority of other nin users such as gon
and killua
in the 2011 anime kite stories changed
somewhat and he does not appear until
the commencement of the Chimera ant arc
after which point gone suddenly
remembers that he had met kite in the
past and the events of the first chapter
play out in a flashback this is a move
to put many hunters onto fans offside
has it removed guns major motivation to
become a hunter in the first place and
the fact that he kind of just
conveniently forgot about kites until
meeting him again is admittedly just a
little bit hard to swallow there is a
running gag in relation to kites use of
the crazy slots ability whereby a number
will pop up can kite will deem it to be
a bad number only for the weapon in
question to end up being the perfect
solution for his situation at the time
and finally a truly useless fact in the
1999 anime kite was made noticeably more
handsome than in the manga or the 2011
version also he had brown hair and to
someone who began watching the 2011
series and then moved to the manga I
find that very very weird but that
pretty much does it for cut if you
enjoyed this video and the content this
channel produced in general then please
do consider donating to the new world
for you patreon because the support of
all of your amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
spot the shower
incredible amount and if you'd like to
join the fun at any time then please do
head over to my discord server where a
wide array of shenanigan retakes place
on a daily basis and finally please do
comment with who what aware you'd like
to see featured on the next Hunter
hunter 101
you